the bite administration is opening two
more emergency housing facilities for
unaccompanied migrant children taken
into custody at the southern border
they're part of a larger migration of
people mostly from central america
looking for work in the united states
and many of them have their lives
uprooted by back-to-back hurricanes last
year
manuel bahr has traveled to that region
and joins us now from guatemala manny
good morning to you
good morning tony you know when we were
at the u.s mexico border reporting two
weeks ago from juarez we noticed
something
most of the migrants we spoke with were
from guatemala now that we are here we
are getting to see firsthand
the effects of natural disasters that
some people say have left them with no
option but to head north
life is trickling back into campus a
town in the guatemalan highlands
that was devastated by floods last fall
that includes the school that was under
water for two months students are slowly
coming back
and we were invited into one classroom
raise your hand if you want to
all of you would like to go to the
united states why would you like to go
for the economy
work jobs 12 year old hadith belinda is
one of them
so the flood devastated your family's
livelihood beverly alvarado
wants to stay here but she doesn't have
hope guatemala's government will do more
guatemala in guatemala there's
no future here she says people just want
to go and create better conditions for
their children in the last
few weeks how many people have left that
you know how many
now six people see beverly lost her home
in the flock
her son's artwork one of the few things
the water didn't take
as a mom she says i'm hopeful that one
day my son will be a professional
it's estimated more than 300 thousand
guatemalans were displaced by the back
to back hurricanes
that caused the flooding which also
ruined crops
the hit to agriculture took away how
most here earn a living
this is what's left of our cook's home
in kampur
she is saying goodbye to friends and
family for what could be the last time
to your single mother three boys
trying to raise the money she hopes to
find work and send money home for her
three boys
the youngest aged two that means
leaving them behind i don't know if i'll
be able to come back one day and hug
them again
only god knows she says
he doesn't have the words
[Applause]
and now dota told us she understands the
border is closed and that it's a
dangerous journey once she is heard can
take up to a month but she is willing to
take her chances trying to get to
houston
which is nearly 1600 miles away
gail oh boy boy you really put a face on
that one thank you very much
manny and the children are so young all
they know is mom is leaving it's hard to
it's hard to wrap your brain around the
decisions that they have to make exactly
and you see the effect
immediately right there and it's it's
this you see hard this decision is for
all these people
you see why they're coming yeah and you
do see why they're coming